[Musik]
das heißt es stets lockenkopf
achso 2009 10 8 ach so ist 2010 erst
einmal einen zweck ist letzten 19
was solches ist es jetzt den linken
rades spiel welches mal weg das ist 19
wirst du hier ist ja nein ja schnell für
den kopf denke ich bin in ihrem kopf
gedacht münster hier habt ihr gesehen
sofort erkannt gefahr gebannt sagte
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein
hallo herr kommt sozialisten heute gibt
es eine silvester idee ja und zwar haben
uns gedacht dass silvester feiern ja
viel in der partie und wollen was
herzhaftes eine torte gibt es schon
jetzt ein anderes silvester rezept gibt
es auch schon weil ich nicht weiß in
welcher reihenfolge video laden egal ich
habe jedenfalls die ist ja drei
silvester ideen eine süße zwei herzhafte
und hier haben wir herzhafter muffins
mit vier verschiedenen cremes und ich
finde das ganze auf einem buffet sieht
schon ziemlich cool aus ja auch und habe
10 18 aber wenn man einen weg ist damit
19 genau wissen welche ich habe sofort
erkannt es war die hier sofort dass er
kam ganz so fort und dieser herzhafte
muffins zeigt das ist ein rührteig also
der ist wirklich super schnell
hergestellt ihr braucht kein besonderes
küchen equipment sondern nur der muffin
backform und vielleicht mit spritzbeutel
nicht schlecht genommen ein bisschen
zeit um inspiration genau ich zeige euch
mal die zutaten von trier zeigt sie
zeigt euch mal die zutaten für den teig
kann ich nämlich dolmetschen auf welche
sprache hochdeutsch
für den teig verwende ich 250 gramm
olivenöl 200 gramm butter milch 200
gramm mehl einen viertel teelöffel salz
einer prise zucker ein viertel teelöffel
natron einen halben teelöffel backpulver
ich habe ich noch die gewürze jeweils
einen teelöffel minze oregano und chili
und ich habe ich hier noch 100 gramm
geriebenen hartkäse und etwas pfeffer
ich habe sie die zutaten für ein blech
für ein blech muffins und je nachdem ob
ihr alle vier ziffern schreibt oder nur
zwei ziffern können wir einfach schauen
wie viele muffins erstellen wollte und
natürlich kommt es auch darauf an wie
groß ihre partie wird ich habe die eier
bereits in der schüssel
dann kam das öl dann dazu dann die
buttermilch da könnte aber auch zum
beispiel benutzen dann kurz verrühren
[Musik]
das ist echt zum rezept ist eigentlich
so ein grundrezept für herzhafte muffins
und daraus könnt ihr dann alles
zubereiten also ihr könnt die so
standardmäßig machen ihr könnt auch
getrocknete tomaten reingeben ein
bisschen oliven hierfür rühre ich jetzt
schon mal die trockenen zutaten mehl mit
backpulver natrium salz und zucker
kurzen ruhm zu verteilen sich backpulver
naht von gut im mehl und dann kommt rein
der käse gibt dem teig jetzt so ein
bisschen im wichtigeren geschmack den
könnte aber auch weglassen und
stattdessen auch schafskäse zum beispiel
nehmen oder auch aussichten im teig und
jetzt gebe ich hier noch die gewürze mit
rein
und wie gesagt hier könnt ihr dann auch
die gewürze nehmen die ihr gerne hat
kurz alles verrühren
unter diesen tag auch schon fertig und
den kann man wirklich wenn man im ofen
backt auch wirklich die vierfache menge
direkt machen und dann bei heißluft
backen und kann so einfach zwei bleche
gleichzeitig backen dann die nächsten
zwei bleche und dann habt ihr in kurzer
zeit ganz viele machen das nehmen wir
einfach einen muffin backform dass es
sich jetzt auch auf papier förmchen wie
kurz einfetten spektrums break und dann
jüngst in die kamera in sicherheit und
dann mit einem 1 fraktion er nutzt den
teig portionieren
[Musik]
und jetzt kann die muffins schon in den
backofen
[Musik]
wir haben gerade unsere unterlage wie
tapezieren sie macht sich größer jetzt
vor mir noch eine hammer also wer mit
einfach eine holzplatte genommen weil
ich halt nicht so ein grosses küchen
brett habe und dann haben wir jetzt eine
tapete
[Musik]
passt doch hallo meine neue küchen
arbeitsplatten für die mango creme
verwende ich 200 gramm frischkäse 100
gramm käse 140 gramm mango das ist
ungefähr die hälfte zwei teelöffel curry
und ein viertel teelöffel salz die mango
wird geschält und fein gewürfelt dann
kann ich sie für ihren und in einem topf
so lange kochen bis die flüssigkeit
verdunstet ist also ihr seht jetzt jetzt
habe ich so einen dicken brei und wenn
ihr euch den part mit der mangostan gold
könnte zum beispiel auch zwei esslöffel
aprikosenmarmelade nehmen oder man kommt
es hier rein in einen kleinen mixa ist
jetzt noch warm ihr könnt auch ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen
aber für den käse ist es jetzt gar nicht
schlimm ich nehme jetzt ein weichkäse
gebt ihnen dazu und kann dann auch kurz
mit zerkleinern
[Musik]
letztendlich nur kurz den einsatz und
kann jetzt auch den frischkäse dazugeben
bisschen salz pfeffer und natürlich
curry
[Musik]
noch gut gerettet
ihr macht dieses million slomo erste
cremig die ärzte geben jetzt um film und
kurz karlstein und dann kümmere ich mich
so lange um die zweite hatte jetzt ein
ich hasse das nehme ich mit schmutzigen
händen zu arbeiten
naja ab heute liebe ich
[Musik]
für die stop creme verwende ich 200 g
frischkäse 100 gramm weichkäse 50 gramm
getrocknete tomaten die waren in öl
eingelegt und 100 gramm zucker für die
schuhcreme nämlich jetzt zuerst zurück
gebt ihnen mixa dann auch die
getrockneten tomaten kurzer kleiner
ich glaube murats zurück herz blutet
gerade aber nicht so
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt wieder der weichkäse
rhein mit mit zerkleinert und dann
einfach mit dem frischkäse verrührt
[Musik]
für die thunfisch creme verwende ich 200
gramm frischkäse 150 gramm thunfisch den
habe ich bereits abgeschossen
er war ein eigens eine prise salz
pfeffer und etwas zitronensaft für die
typisch creme nämlich den thunfisch
unser kleiner den auch im mixer und
verrühren dann mit frischkäse salz
pfeffer und bisschen zitronensaft
[Musik]
und für die lack system verwenden sich
200 käse 150 gramm räucherlachs etwas
pfeffer einen teelöffel getrocknet und
etwas zitronensaft und für die extremen
auch den lachs kurzer kleider und dann
mit frischem zitronensaft und gewürzen
ein bisschen pfeffer noch dazu und wenn
es die creme auch fertig
[Musik]
jetzt sind diese wunderschöne platte und
da kommen jetzt dem auch wenn's drauf
sein denke ich jetzt einfach eine 2009
10 aber ich bin ja ganz raffiniert wir
machen 18 und essen 2 weg und dann wird
es nämlich genau dann mit
[Musik]
nämlich die creme ich habe jetzt hier
die erste und zweite creme bereits in
den sprit wollte gefüllt hier vorne mit
einer großen stern hülle und jetzt könnt
ihr entweder die muffins wunsch war zur
querbeet bespritzen oder einfach jede
ziffer für sich
[Musik]
jetzt mal fertig ich glaube ich hätte
jetzt im nachhinein gedacht die mango
creme lieber darauf und das theater wird
die 89 2000 und jetzt kann man kann das
so aus wie viel stellen auf kalte und
dann probieren einmal probieren
ok komm mal her frank und zwar genau
irgendwie jetzt mal ganz ehrlich wenn du
jetzt frank das ja mark und mich jetzt
irgendwo an einer straßenecke sehen
würde dass wir dafür möchte ich sagen
die drei wochen sehen wir aus wie hier
wird die drei muskeln sich inhalte
irgendwie sehen wir gefährlich aus ja
also wir uns drei auf der straße
irgendwo sehen sehr mal ziemlich
gefährlich ich kann mir vorstellen
allein zu haus das ich noch nicht und
sieht aus wie die eiskalten verbrecher
gelten schießen nasskalten verbrechen
kommt dass auch so ein lieber am rechten
rand die feuchten banken genau so und
jetzt jetzt noch mal war es noch ganz
cooles der rechneten geht es gar nicht
dass nicht nur an tür stehen und es
waren andreas ammer noch hier
andreas scheuer andreas comedians kommt
damit nicht gerechnet haben dass jetzt
einfach zum video auftaucht oder andreas
gesorgt
da andreas ist jetzt da ist bis jetzt
kein staubsaugervertreter nein ist er
nicht aber mit ihm zusammen haben die
zentrale staubsauger anlage eingebaut
genau der firma thomas allerdings bleibt
heimatroman die kurze produktplatzierung
gemacht ja wohl sagt karten auch perfekt
zu benötigen
jetzt dürft ihr probieren 1 ist ein
herzhafter muffins haben eine mango
curry creme thunfisch lachs und ihr job
darüber sagen soll mir mal gesagt wir
essen also die zweite eingefügt hat man
heute morgen noch gar nicht schaffen
alles klar zu kommen auch mal okay
andrea kümmert sich schon um die
silvesterstimmung hier genau auch
probiert steht doch nicht kommt probiert
jetzt mal endlich wahr dass hier das
probiere ich weiß was du probierst war's
okay
sie können mich ehrlich sein
das passiert halt mal tut mir leid nicht
mehr fernsehen so geschmeckt heute geben
was erwarten wir auch sagen zb kein
chilipulver mehr und dann habe ich
einfach getrockneter chilis genommen und
beim 1 1 gemacht das ist so wie wenn ich
sterbe ich habe einiges hat schon
brannte wenig zwei teelöffel pro man
solchen baum schmeckt ja wohl schon
sauna siegerland genau siegel sollen
schon wieder doch inzwischen
eingetretenen wieder genau und aus dem
siegerland kommt da und man muss dazu
sagen die mavs nicht super saftig und
schön locker
sie haben aber die waren sind wenn ihr
nicht so viel zeit hat wie ich und nicht
so viel lust habt die cremes
herzustellen
da geht doch einfach zum feinkost wer
mir auch so ein feinkost bei uns im
globus können wir euch 45 verschiedene
cremes aussuchen und einfach die gremien
spritzbeutel rein film und die muffins
dickeren dann seid ihr nämlich noch
schneller fertig genau außerhalb kein
weihnachtsgeld bekommen dann könnt ihr
das nicht leisten das ding kostet ja
aber ich sage ja entweder macht man
selber oder man holt ja beides macht auf
jeden fall nach und feiert silvester
schön wenn es in dem anschreiben wie ihr
feiert was sie ist und ob er überhaupt
noch eine ganz kurze man hat immer einen
bildungsauftrag oder genau darf ich
könnte sie müssen sich ja bei den
bildungsausgaben auf ganz kurzen leute
zu mir eingefallen dies ja und
verzichtet auf bilder ja nicht so genau
weil wir haben hier schon klimawandel
werde das hier markt daheim schon
bananenpflanzen und das muss wirklich
seit kurzem ein bisschen spaß zu haben
12 minuten
ja es schmeckt natürlich die ganze
feuerwerks branche daran machen und hat
aber ich glaube die nicht da sind viel
zu oft
die tiere sind solche auch dankbar haben
wir direkt beweist doch ich habe nur
dich also machte es besser
[Musik]